hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
we're talking at Freedom Fest in Las
Vegas with crisp rebel of de Cato
Institute the author most recently of
the power problem how American military
dominance makes us less safe less
prosperous and less free Chris this book
is a couple years old but the message is
still as relevant as as ever in a
nutshell how does being dominant
militarily around the world make us less
safe people think that strength is a
function of how much you spend and in
power but of course power is the ability
to get things done to accomplish things
and I think we've confused having
military strength with having the
ability to actually make so you're
saying that 10 years of occupying Iraq
10 years of occupying Afghanistan 50
years of Korea we're not getting things
done right in fact I would argue that
we're creating a sense of dependency
these other countries are becoming are
growing more dependent upon US military
power and it is harder and harder for
them to break for you we're in a moment
now where because of various budget
agreements that were passed the military
the defense budget is going to be cut
yes at least minimally for a year you
hear on the particularly among
conservative saying we cannot afford to
spend any less than we are spending
right now on defense in fact we have to
increase it by X percent or Y percenters
any percent how realistic is that I
don't think it's wise we could spend
more on defense if they wanted to raise
taxes they want to pile on more debt if
they want to cut from other places in
the budget which I'm sure they do the
question is it's not necessary you have
to keep it in context even if the
sequestration this is the Budget Control
Act provision even if that comes into
effect it'll put us at about two
thousand seven or two thousand between
two thousand six and two thousand seven
levels in real inflation-adjusted terms
that wasn't a lean year for a Pentagon
have to remember that the base budget
leave aside the cost of the wars so I
think they're relying on people not kind
of scrutinizing the numbers really
understanding that first of all military
spending is at a historic high right now
and really happen in real than real
dollars yet and you know I mean it's the
case people will always say well you
know what
we have to spend more per person on this
program or whatever defense spending
isn't like that right it doesn't scale
up in the same way some people say that
but my argument would be certainly some
of the efficiencies that we've seen in
virtually every other industry in the
world should apply to some extent in the
military it hasn't been why because it's
not a competitive marketplace most of
these suppliers the most dominant
military suppliers their only customer
and effect is that is the US government
talk a bit about Barack Obama and his
foreign policy how would you
characterize it and what is its critical
weakness or failure I think it's a mixed
bag I have to say just candidly that in
terms of dealing with terrorism
terrorism I think that President Obama
has taken the right approach it's really
about talking about terrorism and trying
to dial back people's most hysterical
fears about a supposedly existential
threat which terrorism does not pose in
it and you see this from the very
earliest days of his administration he
understands how talking about it how
important that is leaving that aside
most of the other things that he's done
as president I'm not a fan of I think
the war in Libya last year was a was
foolish it wasn't particularly costly
but hidden it you know confirms this
argument that libertarians are making
for a long time the president gets to do
whatever he wants Congress completely
rolls over and the president has on top
of that he's invoked the fact that well
the fact that the UN Security Council
approved of that use of force then
essentially why why should we care what
the US Congress thing and now we're
allowed you know it's not clear what
what's happening in Libya right that is
okay well though even that is not a
shining symbol of success we certainly
hope that things work out well but
there's still a lot a lot to be done
what about on the Republican side I mean
somebody like Mitt Romney doesn't have
a foreign policy pan what is what did
what do you take to be his foreign
policy and if we can talk about it in
critiquing right i mean the short answer
is tough toughness and tougher you know
you talks a lot about American
exceptionalism basically made it the
subject of his book what I focus on is
his plan for increasing military
spending he says you're going to spend
at least four percent of gdp over the
next ten years does he doesn't say
exactly when he will achieve that target
but that's a lot of money by my
calculation even the low-end estimate we
need two trillion dollars in additional
spending over the next ten years which
begs the question two questions one how
are you going to pay for it where does
the money come from but equally
important what are you going to do with
this much larger military that we're not
already doing he wants to grow the arm
for the the Army and Marine Corps
considerably what well does that mean
you want to do more Iraq and Afghanistan
style missions because the reason why
President Obama has reduced slightly or
plan to reduce the armor Marine Corps is
because he said well we're not going to
do these nation-building missions well
thank you very much Christie rebel of
the Cato Institute and the author of the
2009 book the power problem thanks so
much